- This is A$AP Ferg, and
I'mma teach you how to dougie.
Nah, I'mma teach you how to ride the bike.
- [Narrator] We caught up with A$AP Ferg,
and he taught us some bike-riding basics,
as well as some advanced techniques.
You'll notice that Ferg
isn't wearing a helmet,
but you definitely should.
Like this guy.
First up, let's talk seat height,
which is ideally at the hip.
- First, y'all gotta make sure
your seat is at the right height.
I like to wheelie, and
when my seat is too low,
I can't keep the bike up too long.
I gotta keep it up a little higher
so I can just throw it up one more time.
- [Narrator] Next up, brakes.
Because before you can ride,
you have to know how to stop.
- These are the two brakes right here.
You have a back brake, and
you have a front brake.
Front brake on the left.
Back brake on the right.
Make sure that they're nice and quick.
You've got the adjuster right here,
just in case it's a little loose.
It works like this.
- [Narrator] Gliding can help
you get a feel for balance.
Here's how it's done.
- I'mma start y'all off with something
very simple, very easy.
You take your left foot,
and you pedal down,
give yourself some motion,
and push.
- [Narrator] Now that
you've got balancing down,
it's time to pedal.
- I'mma teach you guys how to pedal now.
It's not hard at all.
You'll be like me.
And then it's all about the flow.
Don't be scared. Let it flow.
You have to be fearless.
Don't be afraid to fall
off the bike a little bit sometimes.
It's just the flow.
- [Narrator] Once you're
confident in your basic skills,
you can move on to
tricks, like the wheelie.
- It has to be like this.
And you tap your brakes like this
to prevent yourself from falling back.
I'mma demonstrate it right now.
You've gotta give yourself some speed.
See how you tap. You tap, tap, tap.
And that's how you wheelie a bike.
- [Narrator] You can
catch more of Ferg's moves
in the "Plain Jane" music video.
- Haha. A little bit.
I ain't do that in a long time.
That was a little scary just now.
Woof. I feel 9 again.
Thank you.
All right. All right.